come mai durante il video passeremo da
questo a questo non vi spiego il perché
i ragazzi vedrete da soli tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovi deo sono fa
vj oggi sono tornati su geometri dei
ragazzi prima di cominciare voglio
provare a fare una cosa che non ho fatto
l'ultima volta ma bisogna farla perché
si deve fare a news su facebook perfetto
c'è la pagina di facebook di geometri
lush scriviamo un posto per ogni cosa
che succede che fakhri stonare i santi
descriviamo una roba sulla pagina ok a
iniziare con porca poi più avanti
aggiungiamo le cose nel frattempo
giochiamo quindi ragazzi possiamo
iniziare ufficialmente lo sfogo di
geometri dash 2000
eccolo qua time machine mi ero fermato
ovviamente a questo possiamo continuarlo
ragazzi perché adesso ho un modo di
sfogarmi allora ok perfetto che gioco di
mer comunque a parte gli scherzi è dato
per scontato che faccia a faccia fra due
metri che una [ __ ] di forza perfetto
da piano tua madre e della prima cosa la
partenza la biglia prada calmi tutti
perché se conte sono un [ __ ] sono un
[ __ ] se partiamo così ragazzi non
andiamo da nessuna parte quindi piano
piano era difficile che cassi problema
certo piano via okay quello gioca dei
chi cazzo giochi ad ace che mi distrae
l'aido quando gioca sta roba devo
staccare steam internet telefono il
campanello di casa to devo staccare
faccio un pene ok ok orgasmico ragazzi
madonna cosa sto facendo che culo che
culo frega non ci credo sul cazzo
cos'è va piano piano piano piano piano a
caso no mi sono salvato il soldato non
so come sono salvato non so come ragazzi
aiuto oddio porca [ __ ] c'è cosa stavo
facendo sì ufficiale non ce la farò mai
più a rifare questa cosa non ce la farò
mai più nella vita non fatemi domande
lega perché non ho idea di come io abbia
fatto arrivare fin qui c'è è impossibile
attenzione a segnare signori ritorna la
supposta dopo secoli grande supposta
come stai
sei stata nei meandri del culo per tutto
questo tempo brava zia merda zia dai
nomi dell'utri non mi deludere non
tornare nel culo bra razzi a bra la zia
brava di zio bravissima da dove spuntato
lo schifo da dove allora ragazzi
arrivati a questo punto è tragico che
non invece no
invece no ok come non detto sto
scherzando
cosa ho fatto
oddio khamis cosa succede e vabbè troppo
però che cazzo si sta componendo il
livello mentre vado avanti certo ma
qualcos'altro magari cos'è oddio four
camion era giusto era giusto invece
mollato tutto perché sono incazzato ma
era giusto porca di quella [ __ ] 69
tua madre 69 sai cosa vuol dire 69 ecco
perfetto non credo di poter far vi dico
sì ragazzi ci prova l'ultima volta ma
non c'è l'ultimo e se l'ultima l'ha
veramente cioè in assoluto perché è
impossibile non ti non riesca proprio
adesso non ci ri proprio perché dio mi
non ci arrivano mai più nella vita che
poi io faccio un miliardo di tagli
ragazzi ma io provo un miliardo
rivolgendosi cazzo di livello ci sarà
qualcuno
dopodiché ragazzi ho provato a
recuperare la coca cola la terra e
questo è stato il risultato amiloide
coca o un fatte domande sul mio
abbigliamento per favore grazie nido
ancora una di possibilità ma solo perché
la coca cola non è schizzata per bene
dai dai dai dai del lei madre
sai che facciamo sai cosa perché marco è
la musica ma che figo ma è una merda
ragazzi primo tentativo
secondo facciamo secondo volevo provare
a fare il figo perché non si sa mai una
volta nella vita può succedere una cosa
del genere ma solo una è forse potrebbe
essere questa forte ma io vorrei vorrei
arrivare a sentire il drop di sta
canzone problema che non ci arriveremo
mai nella vita trova ok ok e tikwa e fin
qua è fin qua un cazzo
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] concentrarsi non serve a
niente vai vai vai
dov'è che sbaglio qua ok
vabbè ma che cazzo ne so io
[Musica]
ok cosa ho fatto
oh mio dio cos'è che mirka aiuto aiuto
che a casa vai a cagare benissimo sto
gioco perché fai cose che poi non
rifarei mai più nella vita grazie a dio
che sto registrando solo non ci credeva
nessuno lo perdo tutti i file di video
successo ragazzi non ridete perché
successo siamo bravo bravo frano avrai
dai tutte le karame ti darò [ __ ]
caramelle e roba volontà se sono già
molto prima che cristo ci muoio adesso
no no no no perché perché tua madre fa
le borse da zara cazzo aridaje ma è
anche [ __ ] la canzone il problema è che
mi incazzo come niente ma perché vai giù
christian perché spiegano europeo che ok
ok ok ok va bene gamal quante minchia di
cosa il come faccio è impossibile
[Musica]
oh mio dio mio dio mio dio è come un
orgasmo e un orgasmo cazzo e poi
scoprire che era un tram fa bene ragazzi
101 tentativi sono abbastanza e non lo
voglio più fare perché ho paura della
mia vita last processing che cazzo è che
figo ramadan si stanno avere terminati
un ragazzo ma che bomba se non facessi
così come un [ __ ] magari riuscirei a
fare i livelli terminati ma ragazzi e
forse forse a 10 per cento ci arrivo
entro fine giornata forse no
probabilmente vi è chi è gay
[Musica]
c'era qualcuno che stava chiamando i
rinforzi arrivati a quel punto non si
può più andare avanti credo non si può
più far niente non c'è niente successo
non c'è niente che cosa faccio non c'è
niente che karun tra quelli sono
diventato una supposta piramidi temi ha
fatto cagare altamente in mano ma vabbè
che vai vai vai vai piano piano piano
che muori piano timori che record che
record
addio o mio dio eccola noi così mi caso
come così mi caso di brutto perché noi
poiché non so quando riuscirò per a
resistere tifosi la supposta vai vai con
la supposta forza dai che te ne intendi
su possono il culo vero zio che gli otto
madre bravissimo poteva andare peggio
che bello livello tranquillo tranquillo
per me senza problemi ma è capitato col
è bello sono capace io mi farei una
playlist sul telefono solo costa roba
perché bellissimo fa vj la gente ecco
quello è un agente forme zio prove ho
vinto che bello ai livelli così vinco
ragazzi sono questi però il resto non
riesco a farmi cadavere e basta è stato
c'è veramente
disagio controllo qui episodio spero che
vi sia piaciuto un mi piace per l'ultimo
livello perché è stato in grado di
dimostrare la mia professionalità questo
gioco perché è molto difficile come
sento ragazzi servizio è piaciuto è
stato momento mi piace anche a fa già
riferito che come di video plate una
descrizione sempre si discreti ci
mettiamo un po stupito è la ragazza